oh the Chancellor says he wants to
double the number of first-time buyers
so that by the end of the next
Parliament's if they're elected half a
million people a year are getting a foot
on the housing ladder well Mr Osborne
joins me now from breakfast in West
London and very good morning -
Chancellor well let's talk about that
pledge that aspiration for first-time
buys of course if you've got to double
if you want to double those that number
of first-time buyers you've got to have
something to sell to them at reasonable
prices and they're just frankly aren't
enough houses around well I agree with
you we do need to build more homes we
need to make sure all those brownfields
in our cities and towns are being used
for that purpose and then we've got to
help people get on the housing ladder
and things like extending the help to
buy scheme the work we've done with the
new help to buy eisah to help people
save for their first home and tragically
labour now say they want to undo that
and then crucially to answer your
question directly make sure there are
homes people can afford and our new
starter homes plan there's a very
exciting piece of news which is that
over 50,000 people have registered for
this this is new homes that are cheaper
for first-time buyers and that scheme
will really take off in the next
parliament but as Chancellor you
understand the laws of supply and demand
well we certainly hope so and if you
build more houses you've got to say to
some people who already own them then
the value of their house is going to
fall but we do need to build more homes
in this country you know I'm a great
believer in a home owning nation a home
owning democracy where families can get
on that housing ladder and the truth is
that the number of first-time buyers has
fallen steadily over recent years and I
want to reverse that and I want to help
families get on that housing ladder of
course those there are also people
who've got homes and we want to make
sure we don't have a housing market that
lurches from boom to bust and we've got
a new watchdog in the Bank of England
that monitors the house market monitors
what's happening to prices and indeed
last year did step in when they thought
things were in danger of becoming a
bubble and took some action around
things like mortgage standards which
actually took the froth out of the
housing market proving that our new
system is a lot more effective than the
system we inherited something which
might put a bit more froth into the
housing market is of course the new
pension freedoms which are coming into
effect very soon
are you a genuine convert to this
process to allow people almost unlimited
access to their own pension spot or have
you done it because there's a general
election looming and the focus groups
told you to do something for savers well
no tomorrow is pensions freedom day and
this is a revolution that is going to
improve the retirement for millions of
people it's an act of deliberate policy
part of our economic plan that says for
people who have worked hard and saved
hard we trust you with your savings and
I would urge people to make use of the
free guidance service we have and see
how they can benefit from these
unprecedented reforms they are part of
an economic plan that is moving our
country away from being reliant on debt
on to an economy that invests and saves
for its future and it's a u-turn isn't
it in your 2011 budget you cut the cap
drawdown rate to prevent people running
out of money now you're doing precisely
the opposite though we took some steps
actually right at the beginning of the
parliament to change some of the
automatic rules on annuities but I
realized as the Parliament went on
actually with the economy improving with
our determination not just to fix what
went wrong in the crash but to fix some
of the things that have been wrong in
the British economy for many many years
we could go much further and this is a
real revolution it comes into effect at
midnight tonight it's one of the biggest
changes to pensions in a hundred years
and what it means is that people who
have worked hard and saved hard can have
access to their pension savings it is
their money again it's based on the
conservative belief that you trust
people with their own money and we also
provide this free guidance service
there's a website there's telephone
advice face-to-face meetings which will
start next week to help people make sure
they make the right choices about their
future but don't you think with some of
the large amounts of money that are
sloshing around they need a bit more
than a phone call and guidance you talk
about access to their own pension
but some dodgy advisors might get access
to those pension pots and we could be
looking at PPI or worse all over again
but this is of course a properly
regulated industry and the financial
conduct authority on you consumer
watchdog is making sure that the advice
is good advice that the guidance is
there but what they will provide a for
that advice don't they just people will
have to pay for that advice well they're
actually the the guidance that the
government is offering is free so there
is a website with a very large number of
people have already accessed then if
people want to have more in-depth
guidance they can arrange either a phone
call where they sit down for you know a
long period of time with someone to talk
through their retirement plans and how
much money they've got in their pension
or as of next Tuesday you can sit down
with the Citizens Advice bureaux I've
asked them to perform this role and
they're very happily agreed to do so and
have face-to-face sessions with people
so people making these choices are going
to have access to free government
guidance in an area which is properly
regulated by the new consumer watchdog
we have set up but I have to say you
know a lot of it is based on this sort
of rather patronizing assumption a lot
of these questions that people you know
shouldn't have access to their money
that they themselves have worked hard
for and so laid back to 2011 isn't it
that's back to the income drawdown rules
you bought in in 2011 was not
patronizing then no as I say when we
came into office we actually relaxed
some of the rules that existed that said
you had to take out an annuity but we've
now gone much much further this is a
complete revolution it it starts as I
say at midnight tomorrow as pensions
freedom day and as a result of
deliberate conservative policy trusting
people with their own money trusting
people who've worked hard and saved hard
with access to their own savings we're
going to be able to improve the
retirement of millions and millions of
people all right let me ask you about
the SNP and there it is the case isn't
it that so with this
looming you see there's a great
opportunity don't you the Scottish
National Party doing so well against
labour they deprive them of 40 old seats
or something like that you're in cahoots
with them aren't you and in actual fact
ultimately playing fast and loose with
the Union but now I don't accept that at
all I think the outstanding leader in
Scotland at the moment is Ruth Davidson
the Conservative leader and she has
really proved herself not just in the
referendum campaign last year but in
this general election what is clear
however in this general election is that
there will be an unholy alliance between
the Labour Party and the SNP between the
people who want to bankrupt the country
and the people who want to break up the
country if is anyone is in any doubt
they won't be after that TV debate they
can see who would be the weak leader in
that arrangement Ed Miliband who would
be the strong leader Nicola Sturgeon and
indeed Alex Salmond as well in
Westminster and therefore we would have
higher debt higher taxes weaker defenses
because of the Scottish nationalists
propping up ed Miliband and that is not
what the country wants I'm talking about
the Union their Chancellor's economy
when it when it comes to this outcomes
to the security of the Union the Labour
Party are a unionist party with a small
you they support the Union wouldn't you
rather see a Labour MP elected than an
SNP one well I would I want a
Conservative MP elected and their
conservative standing in all those
constituencies with a very strong leader
on the roof Davidson but but well I
thought you should prejudge the election
but I make this observation you're
absolutely right the fact that they
Labour Party which you know was a party
that campaigned for the United Kingdom
in the referendum is contemplating an
arrangement with the SNP who want to
break up the country I think is deeply
disturbing and people know that Ed
Miliband is weak that the Scottish
nationalist leaders are much stronger
than he is and we know who would be
running that government and that would
be bad for the entire United Kingdom bad
for the integrity of the Union but also
bad for our economy because it would
mean higher debts and higher taxes and
so here in West London in inches a can
dyes are worth you know this is as much
on the ballot paper is
in Glasgow or Edinburgh well let me ask
you about your attitude to the Union I
mean if the SNP has expected to do very
well in this Westminster campaign do
very well then in the in the Scottish
parliamentary elections if you're in
governments for the next Parliament and
you're approached by Nicola Sturgeon and
she says right we think we have the
mandate now it was in our manifesto for
these Scottish elections for another
referendum would you rule out any
legislation from Westminster to allow
that well I think that issue has been
settled so did Alex Salmond himself said
that the issue had been settled for a
generation we had the referendum
obviously it was a hard-fought and well
argued campaign but there was a clear
majority of people in Scotland who
wanted to stay in the United Kingdom
obviously I was very pleased with that
result but I think that issue has now
been settled and I think even if you
listen to the SNP leaders they're not
talking about that at the moment but
they are talking about is the extra
debts the extra taxes the weaker
defenses they want to impose on the
whole United Kingdom and that is a
reason why we should be absolutely
concerned about them propping up a weak
ed miliband government let me ask you
about those weaker defenses you courser
refer to the eventual replacement for
Dryden do you want to see a
like-for-like replacements and that
based in fast lane
yes it's the short answer to that
question very good straight answers to
straight questions let's continue in
that vein because of course sir the
Prime Minister did that at that last
session of Prime Minister's Questions
thinly Wendy ruled that's the issue of a
v80 rise something else labour are
suggesting today let me ask you about
that is is that if you are elected you
may well further cut the higher rate of
tax from 45 pence as it stands now 240p
can you rule that out well that's not
our plan our priority can you really not
do increase but as I say you can judge
us by what we say we want to do and what
we want to do is increase the tax free
personal hours to twelve and a half
thousand pounds so people full-time on
the minimum wage don't have to pay
income tax and millions of people are
better off and when it comes to higher
rate taxpayers our priority is
increasing the threshold which you pay
that higher rate the 40p rate to fifty
thousand pounds now those are our big
tax commitments for the couple well
that's only about priorities when you
get that done you can get to the less
issues perhaps cutting that higher rate
back to where it was but as I say if
that was our priority or our plan we
would have made it part of our plan and
made it one of our priorities our
priorities are as I've just set out to
increase the tax free personal ads to
increase the high rate threshold to
fifty thousand pounds and that's a task
we've set ourselves to achieve over the
coming Parliament it's a big ambitious
goal but it's all part of an economic
plan a balanced plan to grow our economy
get our public finances in order make
work pay by cutting taxes for working
people and increase spending on the NHS
each Chancellor thank us
the can either choose straight answers
to straight questions five years ago you
used exactly that formulation about the
issue of v18 no plans to raise v80 and
you know you said it and then you got
into government you said right the books
are so bad we have to put v18 no plans
doesn't mean to say you're ruling it out
altogether well I'm telling you what our
priority is and we've made a big tax
cutting priority and that's that's what
we're absolutely a hundred percent
focused on delivering and achieving not
because it's a nice thing to have it's
because it's central to our economic
plan our making work pay and of course
tomorrow alongside the pensions reform
we have another big step in the right
direction with the increase in the
personal allowance to ten thousand six
hundred pounds again 25 million working
people will be better off because of the
conservative economic plan but we were
doing straight answers to straight
questions we didn't quite get one there
what about this defense spending pledge
two percent of GDP will be spent in a
future conservative-led government will
it on defense
well we've that's what we're spending
right now my boss that was the
commitment in the
but that was the commitment in the NATO
agreement that the conference in Wales
that we organized and I don't think
anyone should be in any doubt about our
commitment both myself of course our
Prime Minister David Cameron to strong
national security which is why we've set
out plans to increase the equipment
budget making sure our armed forces have
the very latest and best equipment to
defend themselves and protect our
country in its interests overseas but
ultimately you can't have strong
national security without a strong
economy any anyone looking at the world
can see if your economy is weak then
you're not you're not able to defend
your national interests as well as when
your economy is strong so it better
basing the Chancellor publicly will be
saying it's not quite a firm pledge all
you've got to say as we will spend 2% of
GDP or more on the defense budget well
we are spending two percentage but it's
not a way on the defense budget hmm well
as I say we've made a commitment at NATO
we are spending it today we've made a
clear commitment to the future of the
equipment budget to increase that in
real terms spend 160 billion pounds
which are a pretty large sum of money on
giving our RAF and our Navy and our air
and our army the very latest equipment
they need and indeed we've made
commitments on the on the size the armed
forces so we've made those commitments
but the to do on the ballot paper is
this choice do you have the do you want
to have the strong economy that is going
to deliver the strong national security
and indeed a strong NHS and the like or
do you want to go back to the chaos of
the past the unemployment the high debts
the high taxes and the like from Ed
Miliband and mr. small do you have any
plans to stand for the conservative
leadership but when Mr Cameron stands
down well look I want to be the chance
Exchequer after the election that's
David Cameron's decision and of course
it's the British public's decision about
whether they return a Conservative
government but David Cameron is standing
to be the Prime Minister for the next
five years there's a huge amount to be
done to finish the job of fixing our
economy and I want to be integral to
that but it's you
Duncan Smith said last week he can't
stand for a full five years you would if
you win you've got a bed in a new leader
and a new Prime Minister and you're on
the prime ministers list presumably you
would stand when that happens well as I
say the leadership I'm interested in is
the leadership of David Cameron he's
committed to being the Prime Minister
for the next five years of course it's
up to the British people now in the next
month or so to make that decision of
whether they want the strong leadership
the economic competence of David Cameron
or the weak leadership and the economic
chaos that Ed Miliband
represents whatever he writes on those
notes okay are we going to see you in a
head-to-head debate with the Shadow
Chancellor with Ed Balls just you and
him well I want to have a TV debate with
Ed Miliband Bulls and Ed Miliband had
his debate last week and didn't do very
well
The Ed Balls why would I have that
debate we've got a format that worked
well that was the format which worked at
the last general election I'm happy to
take part in that format I've spoken to
Danny Alexander he's happy to take part
in that format the broadcaster concerns
the BBC is happy to run that format
we've got a date we've got a time so
let's get on with the that Chancellor's
debate I don't know why I went ahead
though is ahead of it it's not a
head-to-head well we've got as I say
Danny Alexander myself Ed Balls taking
part in that debate I don't know why he
doesn't want to take part in it Ed Balls
and why he's running scared of it he'd
have to answer those questions himself
okay
Chancellor thank you very much indeed
George Osborne there